esta tienda marsellesa es una de las dos
farmacias en la región para acá en
francia que vacunan desde esta mañana y
los voluntarios se apresuraron
es un acto de responsabilidad primero es
mi libertad de poder vacunar me o no y
aprovechó ya que tenemos la suerte de
tener vacunas gratuitas
el cuaderno de citas está lleno estamos
completos durante dos semanas las dosis
se entregarán según las circunstancias
tenemos unas 30 dosis para esta semana y
recibiremos otras que ya están previstas
para la próxima semana están conservadas
a una temperatura de 5 grados más o
menos y durante los próximos 14 días los
problemas logísticos están en juego en
este experimento las dosis de toneladas
se conservan dos semanas en 'nine' este
farmacéutico debe garantizar el respeto
de la cadena de frío
el fc es agua por lo tanto es necesario
disponer de un suministro que se
corresponda lo más posible con el número
de dosis que se van a administrar para
evitar el desperdicio de
la farmacia también es una manera de
llegar más rápidamente al público
prioritario mientras unos 150 centros de
vacunación están desbordados
había citas disponibles mucho antes al
inicio pedí una en un centro pero era
para el fin de agosto en parís las dos
farmacias seleccionadas empezarán a
vacunar esta tarde durante 15 días el
ministro de salud podrá sumas más para
mes y así la experiencia es exitosa